react gilbert casasus professeur
ordinaire en études européennes à
l'université de fribourg en suisse
bonsoir j'ai une barque à sa juste merci
de répondre à nos questions sur arte
france en est à 22 jours la date
fatidique du 31 décembre on est à la
veille d'un sommet européen crucial
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de ce
dîner ce soir en tour sous la van der
leyen et boris johnson de premier
ministre britannique qui on trouve la
porte en disant qu'un bon accord assez
tôt possible selon ses mots mais qui
nuance quand même en disant qu en gros
si anodine il ya londres fera avec
pour reprendre une formule assez simple
c'est du fifty fifty
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui bien malin
est celui ou celle qui peuvent dire tu
peux dire verrous vers quel côté de la
balance on va trancher
je pense très simplement qu' il y a
quelques petites évolutions ces derniers
temps évolution qui se sont aussi à
mettre plutôt acide de l'union
européenne dans la mesure où depuis
quelques jours il semblerait que la très
grande unité qui a toujours été le
maître mot de l'union européenne dans
les négociations avec la grande bretagne
sur le bric site que cette unité se
fissure un peu et je trouve en lisant de
prêt entre les lignes et les mots les
déclarations de rougeole a fondé la
haine différente un peu parfois de celle
d'agréer merkel donc il s'agira de
savoir si oui ou non et jusque dans
quelle mesure boris johnson peut
profiter de ces petites différences qui
sont apparues ces derniers jours mais
sur le fond mais je crois que cela est
essentiel ni à gala merkel ennemi le
président macron sont prêts à céder s'il
y avait véritablement du grandes
concessions à faire ça je crois que
c'est encore ce qui est à qualifier
comme la ligne de conduite de l'union
européenne l'euro d'éviter la république
en marche
nathalie loiseau a récemment tenu à
dédramatiser s'il devait y avoir un audi
en disant qu'il est britannique
reviendrai plus tard autour de la table
quand on substance ils seront plus mûr à
la réflexion donc ça veut dire que
malgré les déclarations optimistes je
pense notamment à un gala merkel l'a
récemment
ça veut dire qu'on se prépare au pire
c'est ça ce scénario guise bel et bien
et c'est pas inintéressant que ça soit
nathalie l'oiseau qui dit ça donc
quelqu'un qui a été tête de liste de la
liste mccaw nicht aux dernières
élections européennes
la position française est de loin la
plus dure mais on peut aussi comprendre
les intérêts français parce que ils sont
la france est en première ligne
il y a aussi peut-être en grande
bretagne une certaine prise de
conscience que le bric site
c'est pas un cadeau et que maintenant il
faut essayer de trouver des moyens pour
faire avaler la pilule aux britanniques
le calcul que fait nati l'oiseau est un
calcul à très long terme c'est à dire de
se dire le bric site va être un échec
et là elle a certainement raison pour la
grande bretagne et que petit à petit la
grande bretagne va revenir vers l'union
européenne
mais ça c'est un processus qui va durer
très longtemps
et du côté de l'union européenne a
échaudé craint l'eau froide
il lui aurait peine à aucun opulent lui
de jouer ce rôle de chat échaudé
vous venez de dire j'espère qu'à ça suce
la france est en première ligne je pense
forcément aux pêcheurs s'il ya nodier de
jean castex ahadi en déplacement à
boulogne-sur-mer et à quelle est la
semaine dernière qu'il y aura un plan
daide pour les pêcheurs français
et que la pêche ne devait pas être la
grande sacrifiée
c'est pourtant un peu ce qui est en
train de se passer non c'est toute la
question jusqu'où la france est prête à
accepter du direct
un compromis mais vous savez aujourd'hui
c'est facile du côté français parce que
on peut prendre une position très dure
mais dans un autre sens si tout à coup
les pêcheurs se mettent en grève ou
créer des problèmes avec tous les
problèmes que le gouvernement français
est obligé de rencontrer actuellement
avec la craie du de l'aco vide
aucun gouvernement elle le pouvait
encore français on est le meilleur
exemple n'a encore envie d'avoir une
crise supplémentaire
il est clair et net que cette question
de la pêche peut envenimer complément
des relations entre la grande-bretagne
et l'union européenne mais le point
essentiel ce sont les conditions qui ce
que la grande bretagne doit accepter
jeudi bien que la grande bretagne doit
accepter et non l'europe doit offrir à
la grande bretagne pour l'accession au
marché intérieur européen
c'est ça le point essentiel maintenant
que je dirais les règlements des futurs
litiges avec la pêche sont vraiment les
points d'achoppement comment trouver un
terrain d'entente justement par rapport
à tout ça tout simplement dans une
négociation on joue
le shaq baleine c'est à dire on m'aide à
côté quelque chose qui fâche d'un autre
côté quelque chose qui fâche mois et on
essaie de trouver un équilibre
l'important pour l'union européenne
c'est de savoir où sont ses priorités
et si la priorité c'est d'être très très
inflexible sur l'accès au marché
intérieur et là je pense qu'on pourra
trouver peut-être un accord à minima sur
les questions de pêche et quant à la
question de la juridiction une question
qui se pose avec pas mal de pays tiers
là c'est clair et net que l'union
européenne bella union juridiction et
elle doit faire prévaloir sa juridiction
ou si dans le cas des négociations
quitte à avoir des commissions mixtes
mais en aucun cas cela doit être une
juridiction britannique où je ne sais
horreur ou autres qui elle doit régler
les litiges avec l'union européenne
l'union européenne a les moyens
juridiques les infrastructures et les
institutions juridiques pour l'a
clairement dit akbar ces tensions
juridique et avec ces institutions
juridiques que les problèmes de conflits
vont se régler voilà ça c'est sa fille
non négociable du côté de l'union
européenne
si ça ne plaît pas à monsieur john
samassa ne plaira pas à monsieur donne
sa pulsation problème donc là l'union
européenne à ses institutions pour faire
conquis pour continuer les relations
avec la grande-bretagne à vos côtés on
aperçoit michel barnier il devait
s'exprimer à 14h30 il n'a pas encore
communiqué qu est ce que ça traduit
selon vous je pense que c'est un jeu
outil doit y avoir véritablement dans
les dernières minutes ou d'un dans les
dernières heures 10 ajustements à faire
et si l'ajustement sont pas faciles et
michel barnier si oui ça c'est
intéressant michel barnier et français
ancien muniesa faire est tombé à
français donc ne peut pas ignorer les
intérêts français sur la foi de la haine
est allemande
ancien ministre de la défense allemande
elle ne peut pas ignorer les intérêts
allemands est là justement il ya un juge
en deux
des 27 c'est ça donc désunion au sein
des 27 selon des intérêts divergents
je ne parlerai pas de deal union puis
surtout pas je dirais des divergences
sont apparues ces derniers temps des
différences d'appréciation mais surtout
ne pas parler de jean moulant et où ce
serait une erreur d'envoyer ce terme
merci gilbert casasus d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur ordinaire en études
européennes à l'université de fribourg
en suisse est évidemment spécialistes
libre exit